good morning everyone my name is naman
jain and today i'll be presenting my
presentation on identification of
transformic signatures for tumor staging
and classification
so
my first
slide is what is bioinformatics
bioinformatics is the use of computer
use of computing and analyzing tools
for the interpretation of biological
data in modern biology and medicines
bioinformatics is a critical
for data and management
computer software's
packages like blast
and symbol
which they rely on internet access are
part of bioinformatics toolkit
transcriptomics transcriptomic uh
technologies are methods for certain
studying and
organisms transcriptome
which is the total number of rna
transcripts
as
organisms information content is stored
in the genome's dna
and expressing through transcriptomics
non-coded rnas form additional rules
whereas mrna acts as a
temporary intermediate molecule
in the information network
the entire transcripts present in the in
the cell are captured in trans in a
transcript room
and which is snapshot in time
transcriptomicine cancer transcriptomes
is very
useful method for studying cancer causes
and identification biomarkers
it
includes
assessing uh alternatives slicing
and poly detonation
detection fusion you know transcriptome
exam
exploring non-coded rnas transcriptomes
and
annotations
and discovering new transcripts
large-scale gene expressions profiling
in new possible
because of recent improvements in high
high through output technologies
so
the types of tumor we are dealing with
are basal like normal like luminal and
chlorine low so basal like is basal like
the breast cancer bl bc is a genetic
subtype of breast cancer that is
characterized by a large cluster of
genes produced by epithelial cells
in the adult memory gland
basal or outside layer because the tumor
are common in young women and typically
relapses quickly blbc is a serious
critical problem so the next is normal
normal breast cancer cell
breast cancer starts in the tissue of
breast breast cancer develops
when cells of breast mutate alter and
expand into
uncontrollably and it results in tumor
mass of tissue
like cyst is formed and then tumor is
formed so breast cancer are malignant
and
it is surrounded by breasts
uh the third is luminal
breast cancer
around two two thirds of
breast cancer of estrogen receptors er
positive or luminal tumor luminal breast
cancer
has a wide range of
histogenic gene expression
profiles
and mutational prior
patterns as well as wide range of
clinical outcomes
and responses in systematic
theory therapy
and the fourth is chlorine law chlorine
no breast cancer is a
molecular form of breast cancer
that was discovered using gene gene
expression
profiling
and has been linked to a poor pro
progenesis
chlorine low tumor have
long
been through
uh through
favor of triple negative phenotype yet
only a small percentage of triple
negative breast cancer tumor cloud and
low so here we are we'll be comparing
two types of
cancers so
we can look here this is the normal
normal like cell and this is the
chlorine low cancer cell so we will
consider this as array 1 and we will be
consider this as array 2 so we have to
make a comparison of all the cancer
types like
numeral luminal normal luminal basal
luminal chloride low
normal normal basal normal chloride low
and basal clot and low
so from that we can find out the
fdr value the p value and the fold
and through
through every detail we can find the
uh
genes related to the group
so how do we find a p value in this
so we can find p value by
using equal to t dot test
start of array one end of every one let
me show you
start of array one is normal like and
normal like here and this is the end
and start of array two and end of array
two
this is start of array two and this is
the end of error 2
comma 2 comma 3
this will
give us the p value
then
we'll add count
in our excel sheet
which is very easy
and then we will add fdr value for that
column of p value as
like
the column which has the p value
multiply by maximum of
count
count is to count divided by third
column of count
and for fold
we can use the formula average
array one
array two so this is the average between
array one array two
and minus average of array two added
minus one minus uh array one
and array two so
from this we can find out
the formula of
food
and
from that we we can find out the
top 10 up regulated genes
so for luminal and numeric normal we
have these luminal chloride in these
luminal basal these normal basal
normal chloride
and basal chlorine
and then same goes for down regulated so
these are the
genes responsible for the
least amount of cancer
regulated regulators
so
we have to make this
from this we can find out
that
these
these these genes are regulated by
luminal genes
these two
and this one
is regulated by the normal gene
and
basal chloride
and these two
are
regulated by the basal genes
and these chlorella genes
are
[Music]
down regulated genes
and so i'll be ending my presentation
here thank you